[Music]
it's about to be crazy
this is about to be epically crazy
in chronological order this is the
second Transformers movie it takes place
during the 90s shortly after Bumblebee
and find a kid struggling with I was
able to provide for his family my
character noise ex-military and I feel
like I'm failing at every turn then I
meet Mirage
[Music]
Pete Davidson is the voice of Mirage
he's found like the rebellious Autobot
you look a good man
go now we're friends
Elena works at the Museum she's
investigating something which brings
Noah into her life who are you uh
janitor really and that kind of opens a
whole new world for us
we're going this crazy Journey with the
Autobots we meet the maximals
we meet the next level of feelings how
big can this guy be uh he eats planets
so like way bigger than a planet
actions there's humor straight to danger
and there's a lot of heart they're going
against their biggest Nemesis ever
[Music]
based anything like this before let them
come
[Music]